pour qui n'a pas l'œil il n'est guère
facile de distinguer au loin les moutons
parmi la pierre cette pierre qui parsème
le Larzac et donne au plateau cette
vision de désert la terre ni est ni
riche ni d'accès très praticable pour
une culture traditionnelle et les
jardiniers de cette nature là ne
pourraient être rien d'autre que les
moutons la région y a quand même trouvé
matière à Industrie la ville de mot s
étaillé une réputation dans le cuir et
la ganterie et fort a su faire du lait
des brebis le fromage qu'on sait mais
au-delà de l'agriculture le Larzac c'est
une terre les 103 ces 103 exploitants
que l'armée voudrait exproprier pour y
installer son nouveau camp les 103 ont
la couleur de cette terre ils y sont
attachés comme la pierre et le calme du
Larzac qui ressemble à leur solitude ne
les prédisposait pas la colère ils ont
pourtant réagi brutalement quand la
défense nationale a décidé d'étendre le
camp il y a 3 ans leur terre était
menacée et on ne leur avait pas demandé
leur avis pour notre part nous payisant
du Larzac nous sommes plein de bonne
volonté il suffit simplement que de
l'autre côté on trouve des gens qui est
exactement le même état d'esprit que
nous et qui ne mettent pas de euh de
dictate et qui ne qui veulent bien
essayer de comprendre de comprendre des
paysans et de comprendre les gens au
lieu de de vouloir systématiquement leur
imposer des
décisions le village de la cavalerie
avait pourtant un nom prédestiné pour
accueillir les militaires il n'y a pas
si longtemps encore les défilés du 14
juillet y faisaient recette et la
population s'accommodait fort bien de la
troupe et des grandes manœuvre jusqu'à
l'affaire de l'extension la contestation
alors a grandi jusqu'à prendre le ton de
la colère si bien que le Larzac a même
aujourd'hui son monument une bergerie
dont le permis de construire avait été
refusé et que des bénévoles viennent
ériger en cathédrale chacun y apporte sa
pierre les ouvriers de lippe n'y ont pas
manqué le Larzac devient un symbole
chacun y trouve son compte de
l'antimilitarisme brutal au refus d'une
certaine conception de la défense
national car qu'il l'admette ou non les
agriculteurs de la région ont été
dépassés on est déjà loin du problème
initial des 103 expropriation l'affaire
du Larzac est
devenue une affaire qui nous dépasse un
peu pour l'instant parce que ça pris une
extension qui n'intéresse pas simplement
le problème
local l''intéresse pas le problème local
du fait
que comme je le disais on conteste les
méthodes et on remarque de plus en plus
que ces méthodes gouvernementales
n'est-ce pas ces prises de position qui
sont d'un autoritarisme qu'on ne peut
pas admettre s'étendent à d'autres
domaines c'est ce qui a créé d'ailleurs
euh à notre égard la solidarité de tous
ceux qui ont des problèmes de dignité
humaine de défense à la au droit de la
vie et ce qui évidemment est quand même
appréciable qu'on ne peut pas rejeter
comme cela dans tout cela les
agriculteurs ne veulent que préserver
leur terre de l'expropriation et rester
indépendant mais indépendants le
peuvent-ils encore au centre
d'information de la cavalerie défil des
Cortes aux passions mal réglé les
moutons du Larzac ne s'attendaient pas à
s'éberger là les non violents se mêlent
aux occitants les objecteurs de
conscience aux militants extrémistes et
c'est maintenant là mé qui est sur
l'avant- scène et en position
défensive localement nous avons aussi
bien le le le soutien de tout l'ensemble
des maères de laavyon de tout l'ensemble
du conseil général de tout aussi bien
les partis de gauche que que de l'évêque
tout le monde se se trouve rassemblé
autour de nous pour nous soutenir alors
face à cette à cette masse qui est
contre qui est contre cette extension de
projet du camp militaire il est sûr que
le que l'armée se trouve devant devant
un problème très grave dans la mesure où
elle veut où elle veut rester en contact
avec avec l'ensemble des Français s'il y
a encore possibilité d'entente les
agriculteurs se déclarent ouverts à la
discussion revoyez le projet d' stylo
militaire il y a peut-être moyen
d'étendre le camp en épargnant nos
terres il est indiscutable que nous faut
pas être nous des des gens qui qui
chasseront l'armée par la
force n pas l'intention de lutter contre
elle de cette façonlà au contraire
si on peut arriver n'est pas une
compréhension
réciproque siôt le plateau rocheux se
développe au Larzac une vaste région
touristique un parc naturel régional
comme s'il était là pour rappeler que la
préoccupation essentielle de l'homme
sera de plus en plus la redécouverte de
son
environnement